[Music]
what up guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
but then today it's a special segment
called
two daddies and a baby have you guys
been seeing all the
monoliths that's been popping up all
over the world don't just pop up again
yeah in romania yeah but it that looks
man-made like
you can see like the welding marks and
you can see like so where was the one
that popped up here that got super viral
i think that was utah utah
yeah like it was in these rock
formations yeah
so i think i don't know if you guys seen
the the i think it's stanley kubrick
movie uh
2001 a space odyssey all right in the
beginning of it it's like a monolith in
in
like the desert or whatever and there's
like a bunch of apes but i guess it like
gave wisdom to the apes and that's why
the apes started to use tools and that's
what advanced society
so i guess that's what they're saying
like an alien dropped that off for like
the alien life form advanced life
lifeform gave that to
us and that's how we're able to advance
society into what we are today yeah
but my question is why the [ __ ]
did they put it like they're so stupid
like if they want to infect a lot of
humans to be smarter
throw it in [ __ ] skid row that's true
or like any
like new york city like somewhere was a
ton of people yeah they're like yo
they're i don't know like the olympics
is happening
and then people are gonna gather so like
throw that in the middle there or like
new york city why are they doing it in
an
area that's so far where no one can get
to yeah
and also the part that i'm like well
they put it in parts where they know
people are going to go
that's the point where i'm like how
could people don't know where they're
coming from like if i mean they they
was if i was like a hiker right yeah and
i [ __ ] saw that [ __ ] in the middle of
utah
i'm gonna like camp somewhere and wait
for the person to come
and pick it up and take it away what
would you ruin the fun what do you mean
like of it no i want to know like who's
dropping them off
who's taking them are they really aliens
or is it just people playing pranks on
us
you know what i mean yeah it's kind of
like those crop circles yeah
look at this dating just cameras [ __ ]
everywhere yeah how can
you how do we not have evidence of who's
planting these and taking them away
we'll just go on tick-tock
you see where pool people are doing it
yeah the people that did it post about
it
oh what was not aliens no oh it was like
initially so they gave it away they go
we went to utah not at the beginning so
it did what happened was it showed up it
starts going viral
and then that's why i'm thinking they're
mostly popping up because other people
are like trying to recreate it
uh and then there was some photographers
there uh capturing they saw a bunch of
other people
super late at night and then uh the
people that came they thought they were
just like uh
wanting to take photos so they always
let them take their turns and we'll go
back doing it because they're trying to
like
set up shots and like with the stars and
stuff
and then the guys were like oh i hope
you guys got your shots and just tip it
back put on a truck and just dip
and then eventually i thought a few days
ago the guys actually posted about them
building and putting it there
so after months after it's been up they
they revealed it yeah man i thought i
really thought it was
aliens i thought i was like but i think
that's true what joe's saying it's like
back then and like say things like there
was no people
say for like the movie base right yeah
so you drop it where like
where would anywhere in the world now
it's like if aliens were there
put it where [ __ ] people would need
it you know yeah not just [ __ ]
a random hiking trail where random
people would that adventures will go
inside i'm pissed at aliens
if they're if they actually exist i'd be
like why what is taking you so long
stop [ __ ] playing games with us dude
just come
out i saw this other article the other
day i sent it to you but it was like
trump
it was like the headline was like trump
knows that aliens are here
but they're not coming out because
humans aren't ready
it was a israeli special forces that
said that
yeah yeah so then that's why i'm like
do we trust him i don't know man just
because someone's cia or special forces
or whatever like
do they really know [ __ ] that we don't
know maybe like someone got murdered
but he's crazy or some [ __ ] yeah i don't
know yeah
there is a uh a canadian military
like guy that was petitioning the
government
to talk about ufos and stuff they're
like you need to [ __ ] talk about this
[ __ ]
did we we released some like uh
oh we saw unidentified objects like we
confirmed it as yeah this year
but i think we just had so much [ __ ]
going on i don't even care yeah it
actually came out
that they admitted they they are ufos
they don't know what the [ __ ] they
are and they don't know where it's
coming from
yeah so do they have it in their
possession like it's just floating in
the middle of a warehouse somewhere no
no they couldn't catch it
they got it on camera oh like like
people in like the
things are trying to like lock onto it
and they did and they were they
basically
confirmed that there is no technology
that would be able to make the maneuvers
fly at that speed
stop correct this course and do that
yeah
because like even a plane like say like
a plane i was watching this documentary
about this one uh
uh plane that just went missing um but
like you say it was like flying out to a
fifty thousand feet and had a
like nose dive in under a minute to
third 30 000 feet the plane would just
explode if it did that
right but like it just can't handle that
physics yeah but
these objects were doing crazy movements
like that and it was also rotating
oh i want to ride in one of those i
probably get a [ __ ]
headache or something it's like that
carnival ride where you just keep going
in circles and you're like ah
that's just fun that one uh admiral that
was on joe rogan he was saying like when
he was fighting uh flying fighter jets
the one that he saw looked like a
tic-tac yeah
it was like underneath the water and it
went
shh like this and you see the water you
know when things come out of the water
the water breaks
then it comes out and it's just like
floating there and then it blasts off so
it's like amphibious yeah like that's
[ __ ] crazy
dude if you know that he was hiding
flying
fighter jets but if they do exist though
i'd be so pissed and i the first thing i
want to ask him is like
why didn't you say what's up like what's
why why you keep why at this point it
feels like they're just these weird
peeping toms like
so weird just observing us maybe it's
just like the
because they're so advanced and they
were just like one of those like stupid
societies
that's probably like the teenagers that
are just taking their parents cars out
just to look like explore
planets also it's the teenage aliens
coming i know right
they're probably not they're like
special forces that of the alien society
because man i'm like if they see us
drawing them all the time right and we
draw we make
aliens look ugly as [ __ ] wouldn't they
go hey i'm way more handsome to this
like show up and go this is what i
actually look like i feel like if there
was like
say human life form or other things that
would evolve into humans
or anything that would like they would
kind of look like us
because we need like oxygen for all
living things we know that we need
certain things
so probably for other planets they might
need that as well and to evolve like how
come humans haven't
like evolved in so many different ways
you know yeah besides like a little bit
of height
and skin color variations yeah but if we
go to the jungle and we see
like a monkey or whatever like we want
to start playing with them and like
i think wouldn't they want to start just
messing with us too
like it's where's their curiosity right
they got to be curious
yeah because they're obviously i mean i
don't know if they're observing us or
whatever but they're like
making they're doing so much work to
hide from us
like why that's what i don't understand
so like we can't even let other
countries really have like
nuclear weapons we have to invade them
we have to do other things do you think
with that technology
not even for them being friendly that we
wouldn't want to get
capture them and kill them and take
their technology before
another country does like the aliens see
how we interact with ourselves and
they're like
there's no way especially america would
welcome them in peace
i think if aliens viewed us we do look
crazy
even if they're like hovering in a ufo
watching like
a football game right oh look at these
weird humans
they're wearing different colors and
they're trying to run each other over on
the field
but they're hugged at the end they're
like you know what i mean that's true
everyone's cheering what's happening
like if they
were able to tap into our internet
they're like wow they're really like
advancing but 60 of the space
is used on videos of them mating video
mating videos
they're like wow look at this technology
called tick tock
and it's just them going who says
they're not here
like amongst us yeah like you're an
alien
like men in black style or you're just
um you have like suits
like and then you can you can just be in
the society but like
no one knows yeah i feel like they will
just look like us
have you seen the bob lazar documentary
no i went on netflix that one's pretty
crazy he like talks about how he works
like what was it called like s4 or
something that secret place in
nevada they had to fly out to on a
secret plane area 50
wood i know i don't think so yeah it's
like next to area 51 or something
but yeah like now he he worked on this
like secret
space thing and he was like saying yeah
aliens exist and all that
and the technologies is just nothing
that he's ever seen and he's been
uh building like jet propulsion since he
was a kid like he's been one of those
guys
and even the way he talks he doesn't
seem like a crazy guy
yeah he doesn't seem like he has
anything to gain or lose he's just like
yeah i saw these things the technology
is way beyond anything i've ever seen
before
you know what's next level technology
that i never thought would happen though
what is delivery man because this video
is brought to you by postmates baby
postmates is freaking awesome because
anytime you need something
does it even have to be food yup you can
get it
because one time i was actually at the
gym when we were doing the a
thousand rep bench challenge and we
actually sold out of water and i
thought i was gonna die and i postmated
two waters to the gym and that was just
the water
just cause i was i was i was benching
for like three hours straight
like two to 16 ounces like two like
liter ones
you ran out of water oh shoot yeah so
i'll die
and i post made it so thank god so if
you're like me and you start thinking
about what to eat for dinner
or what to drink or what to drink while
you're benching a thousand reps
you don't have to go get it yourself you
can get it brought to you and also
sometimes getting into my kitchen and
cooking something delicious to eat does
it make it on my to-do list
yup which is why i've been loving post
meats with postmates you can get food
delivered without leaving the house or
even opening your front door with the
current state of the world in mind
postmates created no contact deliveries
so now when i order from local
restaurants
everything gets left on my doorstep and
the app lets me know when it's been
delivered which is very true
postmates also offers a pickup option
which i've been using to order takeout
from my
favorite local restaurants it's so
important that we support
uplift our communities right now because
they really really need it and what
better way than ordering food and it's
not just all about burgers and sushi you
can get water anything that you name it
from walgreens 711 cvs postman will drop
it off
right outside my front door just
download post meets on ios or android
find your favorites and get anything you
want delivered within an
hour for a limited time postmates is
giving our listeners
five dollars off your first five orders
for your first seven days to save
five dollars on your first five
deliveries
download the app and use code off the
record that's called
off the record for five dollars off your
first five orders
when you download the post mates app or
sign up online
anything you need anytime you need it
post makes it
i think that if aliens were to come out
and we found out
it wouldn't even like make me go oh wow
unless you saw a form of it that a
picture of it or something it looked
weird
like if it was that extreme of like
revelation like if they just announced
like yeah we found out that aliens are
real
we'd be like whatever but if they were
like this is an alien they're right here
i think then we'll freeze if you came to
jk news and you're like yo
this is my buddy eduardo yeah you know
what i mean i'm gonna say one
this is one right here alien wine you
know
and then i would have been like oh [ __ ]
dude that's an alien
but i probably get over it in a week
like unless the alien could do crazy
[ __ ] and fly and stuff
yeah like being able to interact talk
all that stuff
i'd be so curious man like but it
wouldn't um
i think it wouldn't make me
it wouldn't flip up my reality though it
wouldn't make you be like
i'm gonna [ __ ] youtube i'm gonna
hang out this guy yeah or just do it
girl or because imagine you found out
aliens and then
you [ __ ] still have to go to work the
next day how [ __ ] crazy
like the whole everyone's like damn
everyone can't can't even focus on work
because the aliens and [ __ ] yeah i
wouldn't want to go to work
if you guys had an alien like land in
your backyard
do you guys think you would tell anybody
hell no he's my secret
yeah that's my secret dude [ __ ] the
world
not even one person like well i'll tell
you guys you guys could come over
yeah but then you guys would probably
tell every then 50 people will be i'll
be like what the [ __ ] guys it's supposed
to be a secret
yeah and like the cia comes down now
that's too much i'll just be like
do you guys got weed where you're from
can you smoke them out have you heard of
the like
taco bell oh we'll just be friends
because i feel like if the they would
for sure dissect them do whatever
yeah i would protect them it's like the
movie e.t dude we gotta protect them
dude yeah
they don't give a [ __ ] about humans
right now why would they care about an
alien
that's true that's true i feel like the
government is gonna like torture them
and
ask them for technology so they could
have like weapons and [ __ ]
literally just more weapons to be a
power to another country that's on the
same planet damn
that's why aliens don't like us damn
i think that i'll probably be really
into it for a week and then i'll be like
all right when are we going to go
camping
are you like yo dude you got to get a
job start paying rent
like you can't let people free the alien
had a weird special power
that it can turn into anything you want
it to look like right
so like let's say for you like like
let's say the alien you know like when
you see an octopus it lands on something
and it can turn into
like look exactly yeah so like let's say
like one day like
you're jacking off and cut into my
portals yeah
the alien tournament turns into the
hottest girl in the world
but then the alien was actually a boy
would you [ __ ] it still
oh hell yeah i [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of it
and then while it's touching me it
becomes me
and i'm [ __ ] myself
cause i gotcha that'll be crazy i would
ah
i think uh you would would you
if it was a boy but it wouldn't be at
that moment though
yeah well plus it's like because uh
cause it's a chameleon on this planet
i'm not gay
on this planet but is an alien i'm
because i'm not
i'm a heterosexual but that means on
earth for for humans
yeah that's not a human that's true it
could be whatever yeah oh what if they
don't have male or female
like what if they have both or like it's
just different you know
like some yeah it's kind of like in the
in the animal world you know how some
can turn from male to female sea horses
are like that
yeah if there's like too many of one in
order to reproduce
the other one will just switch switch
like sexes that's crazy
and like i think not all ads can
reproduce
right or there's some animals that can't
even reproduce at all
oh yeah they're just like drones or
something yeah it's crazy
that is crazy a lot of the animals in
the ocean look like aliens
if if the alien was like yo you come
back to my home world our home was
dope like but it's dope to them once you
go there it's like hell
no it's like it's like whatever you guys
think is a dopest [ __ ] we got all of
that and it's like
never ending well the first thing i'm
gonna say is can i breathe there
can i breathe like do i gotta wear a
[ __ ] helmet i didn't know the basics
you got oxygen
yeah like we got we got all you got you
can live you do but only you can come
oh [ __ ] but like forever you can't come
back to this
to to this world yeah oh [ __ ] but
it's forever because if elon musk was
like yo we're going to put you
right now or in like a year on a
spaceship
that you'll have enough food until
you're old and die but just
shoot out but you go the farthest any
humans ever gone i would do it i would
just give me a year of doing whatever
the [ __ ] i want give me enough money
save my goodbyes [ __ ] as many people as
i can yeah
i would do it you would do it right now
at your age right now oh
there's too many i'm so into space and
[ __ ] like that there's too many things
on earth that i want
and i like like i think i love earth
nature
way too much i look up at the stars i'm
just like
damn we'll never because they say have
you seen pictures of
mars you go there and you're like i'm in
hell
not even more just shoot me out into the
furthest abyss so let's say
you go to pluto you're like i'm in ice
hell
what if they send you to like [ __ ] uh
i don't know mars or some [ __ ] right and
you land there you're by yourself
everything looks like baker's field
that's literally what it is you're just
going to know if i'm on mars alone no
i want to be shot out like like give me
movies give me whatever
thing it's like a long [ __ ] solar
system out of our planet this phil
thinks he's gonna be flying in the
emirates camp i've never i'm never
i'm never landing oh you're never
landing it's just constantly flying yeah
oh you know what they're saying like in
the future right um
when there are voyages where like humans
need to colonize a certain
planet like we have the eggs and sperm
it's gonna be several generations of
humans
on the ship until they land yeah so it's
like that's so you know you'll be born
into
you and you're gonna die on that ship
yeah you're gonna be born on the ship
and then your job is to pop out a
[ __ ] kid
and keep going and you live and die on
the ship until you get to your
destination
was that what it was for um what was
that movie with was it sandra bullock or
wait the one where he accidentally wakes
up and then he wakes her up
was that with chris pratt that's chris
pratt i forgot what it was but it was
like fake interstellar right
and then by the time the people woke up
it was like a garden and [ __ ]
yeah yeah that movie was tight that was
that was they were not they were gonna
arrive there
right uh i'm thinking about the one
that's um
they go with i think what's interesting
was like plan b
we have enough of this what's that
oh no i think you're talking about the
robot that raised the little girl
was it that one no oh oh oh that one i'm
talking about where it was like plan b
um uh so oh no it wasn't a seller
because they were never
expected to really leave so he sent her
off
um with basically enough sperm and eggs
to raise those people and
that right that's not interstellar that
was are you talking about is that a
sandra bullock or matt damon movie that
might be something else that might be
the matt damon one
but i thought there's too many damn
space movies that are similar man
wait because i thought no interstellar i
swear to god it was like that's matthew
mcconaughey
with anne hathaway his daughter cause
wasn't it right yeah that's not stuff
[Laughter]
no no hold on really quick he did send
her out right
the the what's the guy from batman
michael kane michael kane
but knowing that all the [ __ ] that
they've been working on was [ __ ]
that they were never going to figure it
out so we sent them there to basically
find a a plan that they could live on
yeah
and repopulate it all right because the
whole earth was about to die yeah yeah
so they knew that they weren't gonna be
able to actually prove it but then he
did figure it out
yeah and then they were able to create
that thing that ship that went there
yeah but they had enough plan b was if
they can't
to go through the black hole no to
basically be popular they have oh yeah
sperm and eggs and [ __ ]
damn that movie's so deep i need to
watch it again i just remember the
the black hole part where he was been
trying to tell her
and it's like remember when that book
failed that was dead
oh yeah when it's like all the inner
dimensions start talking together
when i'm driving i always put the that
scene i just type in interstellar
um you shouldn't be watching that scene
while you're driving
no i don't i just put it for the audio
it makes me cry why
it's sad because it's like i'm trying to
tell you as a spirit you dumb [ __ ] i'm
i've been here the whole time oh not
that far the one way i've been behind
these books the whole time
where she's dying and she's like oh you
go i have my family here now she was
like she was like go be with that that
one girl
you know what the daughter is a grandma
i need to watch it again it's just
blowing my mind right now
[Music]
you